[Musique]
durant le confinement les travailleurs
sociaux du département et de la caisse
d'allocations familiales ont été
fortement sollicités des situations
d'urgence sociale grave ont été relevées
afin d'accompagner les familles
réunionnaises dans la phase post
confinement une action intitulée
week-end de la parentalité a été mis en
place
c'est au village de corail à l'ermitage
que s'est déroulé ce premier week-end
pour quarante familles alors si vous
voulez les travailleurs sociaux dès le
début du conflit demande gens ont fait
remonter des fraudes et des réflexions
des familles parfois des situations
difficiles
et
durant deux mois ça peut être l'homme
pour un cours certaines familles
évidemment le suivi social c'est s'est
poursuivie beaucoup de familles ont été
impactés à travers ce confinement
les enfants eux mêmes ont été impactés
et bien aujourd'hui nous avons souhaité
redonner un nouvel élan pour faire en
sorte que ces familles qui ont été
confinés et me retrouve le sourire la
joie de vivre le bien-être et bien tous
ces ateliers ont contribué à redonner du
bien-être aux jeunes enfants comme aux
parents renforcer le soutien à la
parentalité auprès des familles une
orientation prioritaire prise par la
collectivité dans le cadre du plan
stratégie pauvreté de l'état c'est une
expérimentation qui a été mis en place
par le département et la caf qui par la
suite après un petit bilan qu'on saura
devoir pour les prochaines éditions pour
que ces familles qui ont été recensés et
justement par la carte le département
les familles les plus
en difficulté pour pouvoir étaler plus
après sur les années à venir pour mettre
en place cette action
cette action offre un séjour de deux
nuitées aux familles et propose diverses
activités et ateliers pour allier moment
de convivialité et répondre aux
questions relevant de la parentalité
travail tous les à côtés pour payer eh
bien pourquoi tu le payes tout ça la
série tf1 vidéo sur votre compagnon
irish toile mais nous ont pas tout le
temps il doit en pareille arrive jimmy
grondin l'abrapa my mama les portes des
musées de vienne et la planète où donald
et comme on dit ça envoie les ateliers
ac c'est bien sûr c'est les moyens
propres locaux
une bonne activité chandail des quotités
raison
raté c'est génial les secours
aussi et
mais passer du temps à jouer avec notre
retard et métro faire mieux
le week-end de parentalité sera réitérée
en faveur de 1000 familles sur les six
week-ends d'août à septembre 2020
[Musique]